Jesus says that he's praying to his
father. Does that line up with Islam?
Wait, let him answer.
I can't answer that for you because find
a verse from the Quran that says Jesus
is a Muslim and I'm going to say, can
you accept this?
There there's no verse in the Quran that
says that it does.
Give me a verse that says Jesus is a
Muslim. It doesn't exist.
It's
[Music]
not
scriptures that you're referring to, we
don't believe that they're authentic. So
you're using the scale that we don't
agree with to measure the Quran and
measure what the prophet wasallam is
saying. So that's where
like misunderstanding come from
the scriptures,
right? So so this is the the response
I'm used to. Remember I told you how
like you know the Muslims the Muslim I
talk to they'll say oh well we don't
believe that what you have is the
authentic versions of the scriptures
that the Quran is referring to. Right?
that some as somewhere down the line
they've been corrupted, right?
Christian scholars like don't agree on
that.
Not Christian scholars. No, no, they
don't. But look, but let's let's go with
this like let's say I grant this, right?
That what I have is not the authentic
scripture. I think that that still poses
a problem for for Islam because you're
saying at one point these scriptures
were the pure word of Allah, right? The
angel revelation of of Allah, Torah
revelation of Allah, right? You would
agree
what the prophets that you mentioned
preach was pure,
right? Was pure and it was uncorrupted
and untampered with at some point when
it first got revealed and was preached
by these prophets, it was pure,
uncorrupted, right? And at some time
later down the line, corrupt men
tampered with it. So the problem with
that with me theologically is, you know,
in Islam, the Quran says that
none can change the words of Allah,
right? None of the revelations of Allah
can be changed.
So if you're saying that at some point
Allah's revelations were changed, that
literally goes against what the Quran
says.
We don't believe that people can like
receive their revelation and then change
it themselves. We
say it again.
We believe that the Quran is the only
book that would never be changed, but we
don't believe that with the previous
scriptures.
Right. So I I so I I I I'm familiar with
like I know that you believe that but
but the Quran doesn't say that the Quran
doesn't say that the Quran is the only
book that's not going to be
it says it never mentions that the
previous scriptures were not temperate.
In fact it mentions that they were
tempered.
So let's talk about this. So are you
familiar with um chapter 15:9 where it
says that Allah sent down the re um
fire but it talks about the reminder how
he will guard the reminder. He'll always
protect it. you familiar with that? All
right, let's just, you know, I'm I'm I'm
only a English hi. I don't know the
Arabic. Let me see.
So, this isn't see this this is this
part is important. Okay. So this is
chapter 15 verse 9 um al-hra or yeah
al-hra where it says
uh right here so we even we revealed the
reminder and lo we verily are its
guardian right so the the reminder we
reveal the reminder that's Allah's
revelation now you would think that the
reminder is the Quran right
I'm not familiar with the verse so I
can't tell you what fair it means and I
don't think you would be able to
I'm I'm about
I'm about I'm about to
unless you study the Quran, study taps,
which is
a very extensive study, you will not be
able to
I'm I'm about to show you. I'm going to
show you. I studied this. Okay. So,
look.
So, the reminder, he reveals the
reminder and he promises to protect the
reminder. Now, according to the the
Quran,
the Torah is the reminder, the book
revealed to Moses. Look, I'm going to
show you.
I'm about to show you.
This is chapter 21
verse 48.
It says, "And we and
can you read Arabic?"
Oh, perfect. That's that's perfect. For
the English uh people,
it's just the word is the same.
Mhm.
But it does not mean the reminder. Vikra
just means uh like
it's the reminder,
not a you're saying it's a reminder.
Yeah. Vikra is just a general term that
could be used for different
Okay, beautiful. So, but so we do see
that the rora is referred to as a
reminder, right? Maybe not maybe not the
reminder, but a reminder. I understand
what you're saying.
And I don't know the exact like tips
here of the verse that you mentioned
previously. So, I couldn't tell you if
it is mentioning the Torah or not,
but I could tell you that the word could
be used for many different things.
Sure. So, so not the reminder, but a
reminder. So let me yeah I that's what
general word
yeah general word for certain things
right okay so now so now let me show you
this
so so my argument is that the Torah is
the reminder that's my argument right
now so I'm going to try to substantiate
that
you don't have like any proof
I'm about to show you I'm about to show
you look
so I just wanted to show you that the
Torah is referred to at least as a
reminder and then I'm about to show you
that it's referred to as the reminder so
we go same chapter Oops.
Sorry.
Is that the tough zero or the verse?
That's the verse. Okay.
What verse is this?
Oh, 548. Oh, yeah. We can Yeah. Did you
pull that up? You're too sneaky little.
That's a good verse, though. But okay.
So we can we can get to 548 next but so
look this is uh same chapter 21 verse
105. Okay. Uh you can read the Arabic so
you can see but it says and verily we
have written in the zabore the psalms
after the reminder
my righteous slaves will inherit the
earth.
Okay. So you see uh so now the zor is
the psalms. What came before the psalms?
But you're that's where the confusion
is. You're talking about the word of
zikur which you don't fully understand.
I do.
You don't. What does it mean?
It's it's the reminder. It's it's what
brings remembrance. It reminds the
people to follow God. Follow his
commands.
I wouldn't be able to tell you what it
truly means. And I know for a fact you
wouldn't.
Why? Why are you doing fun fact?
You don't know Arabic, let alone know
what Muhammad is trying to say is that
the word itself doesn't exactly directly
imply to the scripture that you are
referring to.
That's what he's trying to say.
So that and that's what I'm showing. I'm
showing that literally this
the word could be used like the same
exact word could be used in different
ways depending on the context and
you need to know the context and the
meaning of the word to be
right. I I'm fine with that. Here's
here's my thing, Muhammad. I'm saying
that cuz so when I showed you that the
Torah was referred to as a reminder,
you're you're saying it's not the
reminder. It's just a general term that
could be, you know, used in certain
different ways. So, right now, I'm
showing you that it's not just a
reminder, but it's the reminder.
That's what I'm telling you. I don't
think you understand that it's not it
does not work like that.
But does it at least say that?
It does say. Yeah.
Okay. So, it it does refer to the Torah
as the reminder, right?
No, it does not. at the time when it was
refused to because people started
changing it up and adding their own
innovations to it. So that's why it be
did not it wasn't the word of God
anymore. So that's why God had to send
it out another reminder, another book
that was revealed and that's what the
Quran is saying in that verse where it's
like it's the ground basically confirms
all the other books that were revealed
down as like those were also reminders
but because people changed so because
people like you know um went against
that rebelled against like the law that
was sent down. So then that's when the
ground had to come down was like here's
the final message this time God's going
to be the one preserving it instead of
leaving it to humans to preserve it.
Okay. So, just to be clear, you're
saying that that was a reminder. These
scriptures were a reminder during their
time, but they got corrupted. And so,
now we have the Quran, the uncorrupted
reminder that can correct things, that
can fix things up. Okay.
It's reaffirming the message that was
already sent down.
Gotcha. Okay. So, this is my problem
with that. I understood what you said.
This is my problem with that. Okay. My
problem with that is is that there the
Quran doesn't say that it it when it
says that it protects the reminder like
Allah will protect the reminder and what
we see is we see that the Torah the
scripture that I have is called the
reminder and even in chapter 16:43
it calls us the people of the reminder
and the Christians it says ask the
people of the reminder you know yeah So
if we're the people of the reminder, if
my scriptures are the reminder, and then
the verse says that Allah will always
guard the reminder, why would why would
we go against what Allah says there
thinking that he allowed the reminder to
say you can't do your own tests here
without knowing Arabic, without knowing
all the other sciences and knowing the
context of one diverse, you know, like
the word that you're using the reminder
could be used for different like for
different books for different meanings
for a lot of different things.
So it depends on the context of what
it's saying cuz she mentioned sometimes
it was above the previous scripture and
sometimes it's about and sometimes it's
above something else.
Okay. I mentioned before like even in
the Bible there's very little direct
implications as to what it is. And from
what I understand the point you're
trying to make is uh why would the why
would we reject the old scriptures? Why
would we need the Quran pretty much
after that? But the fundamental belief
here being the Quran was reveal revealed
and it reaffirms aspects of the old
scriptures. But obviously like Fatma
stated some somewhere down the line they
were corrupt. So you have the Quran as a
credible feasible and usable source.
Yeah.
To track back down the sayings,
teachings and understandings. For
example, if we take if we reject the
idea of crucification and we say, "Oh, I
saw this scripture, this scripture, this
scripture that shares correlations with
the Bible, but it doesn't there there
are parts that are different in the
Bible." So, do I agree with the Bible or
do I agree with the scriptures that came
before it or the scriptures that were
there during it or some historians that
wrote it up at that time? Would you
agree with the Bible, Bible's
interpretation of Jesus Christ or would
you agree with some scriptures
interpretation of Jesus? You would go
with the Bible as a Christian, you know?
Yeah, because the Bible is the
historical precedence of Jesus life.
That's why
that's what the Quran is.
So, okay. So, let me go with you guys on
this. Okay. The previous scriptures were
corrupted at some point. Therefore, the
Quran came as a you know um as a
basically like um
like helping correct things and fix
things and point them back to the truth.
Right? Okay. So, here's my question with
this. Okay. When Allah says that none
can change his words, nobody can change
any of the words of Allah, what does
that mean?
That means the current Quran that we
have today is the same one that was
revealed 1,400 years ago. So like it was
not corrupt like the same way that a lot
of people recite Quran today, the same
one that was revealed to the community
and it hasn't been changed since then.
Even like passing down from generation
to generation, it's been the same on. So
you're saying that that's only about the
Quran. Those words, the Allah's words,
the the previous scriptures isn't
included in Allah's words.
Those were God's words as well. But
Allah chose like those nations as like
you are going to be like we chose you.
We chose you, but you are also given the
responsibility of conveying to the rest
of the world my message to the rest of
the world. Therefore, you I'm giving you
this book. So you're going to have to
use this book to teach the other like
the rest of the world. because they
started adding like different
innovations. They started changing
things up to like make it benefit for
themselves.
So that's where things kind of started
shifting and changing them.
Okay. So, so just just to be clear, I
make sure I understand you. So they are
Allah's words as well, the previous
scriptures, but he allowed them to be
corrupted.
I think also uh sorry
like uh when you think of like when you
say like oh Allah's words are
unchanging, right? if if that if if
that's what you think translation also
matters as well but what what came to my
mind was rather so like uh like it's an
eternal command for example right so we
believe that God his speech has no
beginning nor end right that there was
no um like beginning of the has always
existed the attribute of God has always
existed it's never has a beginning nor
end because that's what we believe for
God to be God has an omnipotent presence
and and status such that uh like none of
his qualities or traits have a beginning
or end, right? So, when there's words of
speech, it could be that like this is
kind of what I'm I'm not really sure
which context you're referring to, but
this is like kind of what came to my
mind as well is that like his words are
unchanging.
It's a reference to the Quran, but it
also can mean that like oh like no one
can change his command for example or
change because none of us have the power
to do so.
So, what you're saying is that that
could be none can change Allah's words
can just be uh referring to his the
divine command that he's given. And so
his his command is unchanging but what's
written in text can be changed.
I I think there's also this reference to
the Quran. I'm assuming this is like my
main assumption. But I want to add on
this is also like another thing that
like with regards to God's words being
unchanging, it's an eternal uh
attribute.
Got you. His eternal speech that cannot
be corrupted. Got cuz it's
but also what we believe in the Quran as
well is that the written Quran is called
is two things. Kalami and Kalami. These
are the two like different attributes.
is the uh is the actual speech of God.
Right? And is the speech of God in which
that is eternal whatsoever. It is
unchanging and everything. This is the
the words of the Quran. The spoken word
of the Quran is this is the this is the
category it falls into is the written
one where it is uh then transcribed by
and and and preserved in a text. Got it.
So the physical book of the Quran is
under the left
and this is like the where it's
physically contained in there. But the
spoken word which we recite and
everything is what we believe to fall in
the category which is the eternal word
of God.
Very interesting. I I I never knew that
that category. So thank you for that.
That's that's interesting. So Kam Nepi
and Kalami
Lei and Nepi
Nepi and Lepsi. Okay. I'll have to
repeat that over and over. But thanks
for that. What's your name relative? Uh,
Kahhan.
Kahhan. Yes.
My name's Avery, by the way. So, I I I
forgot I never introduced myself. Rude.
Okay.
But I have a quick question. Did you
like did you did you ask like permission
to start filming and stuff or
I didn't ask for permission? We just
walked up and just started talking. I've
been I've been filming myself since I
was like way back down there.
Yeah. Cuz like we're also students and
like you know like I understand like you
do you want do you want your Yeah. Do
you want it to be blocked out? cuz I can
I can you know um make sure that your
face and
I think that'd be
okay. I got you. Yeah, of course. Is
that for everyone? Got you. So, and I'll
give you guys my channel. You guys can
can see it. I'll send you guys a video.
You all your faces will be blanked out
in this conversation. Okay. I promise
you. All right. But yeah, guy I I man
this is uh I learned something new. I I
like this. So, okay. So, now this um the
Quran came to correct. I want to I want
to touch on that. Okay. So um if the
Quran came to correct that what they had
is is corrupted. The Quran came bringing
light and correcting what used to be and
pointing them back to the truth.
So here's my question with this. Okay.
And you brought up 548 which I said we
was going to get to. Right. So in that
context 543
Allahh Allah says to Muhammad he's
talking about the Jews. There was a
point the context is that Jews tried to
come to Muhammad for judgment. U I don't
know maybe you guys might be familiar
with the story some people among the
Jews committed adultery they came to
Muhammad and said give us a judgment you
know and Muhammad responded and said
bring the Torah you know so this verse
was revealed with that context and it
says why do they come to you or how do
they come to you when they have the
Torah
say I've done my 4 hours for today
hey Russell good to see you again
don't worry about those guys they're not
they're not dangerous
Thank you.
These guys are cold. I like where
they're going.
Appreciate you, Russell. I
joined halfway.
Be safe today, Russell.
So, yeah. So, 5:43
it says, "How do they come to you for
judgment when they have the Torah in
which Allah's judgments are in?" And
even so, even though they have it, they
still turn away and act like hypocrites.
Um so my question is if the Quran is
coming to correct the scriptures and
stuff like that and the Quran is what's
needed to you know you know point them
in the right direction why then is the
Quran saying no why do they they don't
need to come to you Muhammad they have
the Torah already that has the judgments
of God what are you guys
so I think this is rather like reading
this myself of course the context of
this explanation you're like I'm going
to give this like my I haven't really
like studied this scenario So and then
again I'm going off of like a bit of
like you know unfamiliarity with it but
just reading the verse itself says like
um I guess maybe the translation is
important that why they come for a
judgment when already have the Torah
they have a Torah containing Allah's
judgment then they turn away after all
are they not true believers so I think
this is also referring to because
there's also an acknowledgement that the
Jews of Medina did did recognize that
this is the Messiah the prophet that
they were looking for that they were
pro prophet not messiah right
uh sorry yeah prophet Messiah was Jesus
the the next prophet that they were
going to come. Um and um and I think
they they recognize that some of them
did recognize because even one one of
the prominent leaders said that oh I
know that this is the prophet that we
waiting for. However, I refuse to follow
him and I will be his enemy till the
end. I forgot the name of this person in
particular as well. But um I think this
is rather like God pointing out to like
kind of like you know uh kind of
pointing out to them like oh you have
the Torah already, right? You already
have the Torah. you're supposed to
believe in this. However, you're going
to the prophet for judgment because you
recognize that this is the prophet. This
is the one that you're supposed to
believe and follow. So, they they it's
kind of I think it's rather like
pointing out their flaw that they
already have. If they really believe in
their book, if they really have the
firm, you know, like believe that this
is what they have to follow, they would
they already have the judgment there.
But rather, they're going to a secondary
source because they know that this is
the prophet that they were waiting for.
This is the prophet they're supposed to
refer to. That's why they're going to
the Muhammad peace be upon him to ask
for that judgment. Well, uh, actually,
it's not it wasn't because of belief.
They went to him because they didn't
want to obey the Torah because according
to the Torah, the the situation that was
going on, it was fornication. And so,
they went to Muhammad to try to get a
lesser punishment that the Torah gives
in the Torah was stoning. They
fornicate, stoning. Right.
Right. Right. Good. Good. So, they went
to Muhammad to try to get a judgment.
Right. And then, so what Muhammad said,
he said, "Bring the Torah." They brought
the Torah. And then when they brought
the Torah, he said, "Bring someone who's
learned it so he can read it." Cuz
obviously Muhammad couldn't read it.
Right. Right. And so when he brought
someone who was learning to read it,
they tried to they put their hand, the
hadith says they put their hand over the
verse of the law when it came to
fornication. So they were trying to hide
what the Torah actually said about this
law. And they wanted I don't know if
they're trying to trick Muhammad or if
they just wanted a lesser punishment.
They wanted they didn't want to follow
the Torah. That's that was clear. So, um
they I I don't think it's necessarily
that that they believed in Muhammad as a
prophet that they can do this or I think
that they was looking for an excuse to
turn away from the Torah and not follow
it. They didn't know they didn't
anticipate their mama was going to say
follow the Torah. What does your Torah
say about it? You know, that that has
God's judgments in it, you know. Um so,
they got caught with their hypocrisy and
they got caught, you know, trying to
conceal. So, but my point with the verse
is that the Quran is holding them to
their book for judgment, not the Quran
itself. They don't need the Quran to to
judge by cuz they already have God's
judgments in the Torah.
But then then again, like as you
mentioned, stoning as a punishment for
adultery is also in Islam.
Okay.
But then like, you know, if it's like a
marriage or like someone who admits to
adultery, if they admit to it, they are
then stoned as punishment. If if the
laws are similar in both religions and
you know referencing the other one is
for the Jews like is that not like a
valid thing to do
to
because if the laws the same in both
they're referencing that as well right
but it was it wasn't at the time I don't
think I don't think I don't think at the
time that that was cuz it's not well
they say that the they used to be in the
crime but it was abregated the the verse
of the verse of stoning they say it was
abregated um but it's still lawful so
I don't know yeah I think uh It's
interesting question.
Yeah, I think uh like I'm not sure of
the specific context of the verse.
Neither are you. As we can tell,
say it again.
To understand the verse, you have to
study it and study its context and study
the text here, which neither of us have
done. So when we're talking about it,
you say neither of you guys or even me,
neither of us are prepared. Yeah, I
think I think like if we're speaking of
a verse that we have not studied, we're
just all just putting our assumptions of
what happened and what could have
happened.
Yeah, I'm I'm telling you from what
understanding of Islam put into that
verse. But
yeah, I'm I'm not doing that, brother. I
promise you, you Muhammad, I I'm telling
you where I'm coming from. I'm I've
studied I've studied this
to make taps. It's like 15 like
different sciences that you have to
fully understand to be able to make your
own tapsier. Well, you have to read the
text here of the scholars.
Yeah, that's that's what I'm doing. I'm
not like trying to make my own
interpretation. I'm just I think it's
clear. I think it's clear saying that in
order to get a better understanding and
a more accurate interpretation and a
more accurate answer that you're looking
for,
it'd be best to speak to a direct
scholar,
okay, who has done
who has an understanding of the verses
and who has done a deep direct study.
Yeah.
For example, I could go through 10 years
of med school, but I would be nowhere
near somebody who's been a surgeon for
the last 25 years, right? And for
example, I could know how to drive, but
I wouldn't be as good as Arn on the
track, right? Is the time that you've
spent behind it. So, you're speaking to
a scholar who has done and who has
genuine understanding, genuine academic,
spiritual, and social understanding of
what the Quran and what Islam stands
for. I think you would get a better
answer. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I you know it's unfortunate
I don't have I guess a shake with me
right now but you know you guys are the
closest thing I found and it's just
discussion.
We also have people you can contact
discuss this. We have a lot of scholars
that we're in contact with and if you
like I can give you their email or their
number you can discuss with them if I
think you know of course you know we do
our best and we kind of just speak to
the general masses questions but of
course when you know the nitty-gritty
you know unfortunately we're still
students. We're, you know, we're all
we're all on a journey of learning and
we're not at that level, I guess, to be
able like, you know, to be able to, you
know, we want to, we, you know, we want
to be able to give off the right
message,
but we we don't want to, of course, say
the wrong thing, course,
even when it comes to the Bible or
say yes and and same here. And and
that's that's a humble attitude to have.
Like I, you know, I I like even me like
I study the Bible a lot. Like I talk
about it a lot. I'm not a theologian.
I'm not a scholar. I know what I know
and I know and I know what I don't know
and I I don't know a lot, you know, and
I'm and I can accept that. You know what
I'm saying? And so when I get in these
conversations with, you know, brothers
like yourselves, I don't expect you guys
to be able to explain everything, you
know? We could we could talk about
stuff. I mean, you know, we reached that
limit of our understanding. We reached
our limit. You know, I it's just I
definitely appreciate you guys with the
conversation.
Reaching the limit. It's about the
experience and the time you spend in
something. And how long have you been
studying Christianity?
Uh since I'm 29 now, so about 12 years
that I been studying myself. Seriously,
if you look at a Christian theology
who's been doing this study for 30
years, it's not necessarily that he's
capped his understanding like you will
never really cap your understanding. You
will forever be learning
understanding. It's not really a
capacity of understanding.
It's not like a video game where you
reach a certain level and that's it,
you know. So,
you know, if you were to talk to a
Christian theologist, he might teach you
something that you never did. Like you
said,
like same thing when it comes to a shake
or an Islamic scholar, they're going to
give you better interpretation, better
answers, more direct and clear answers
to help you understand
Islam in general.
Yeah. So, yeah. And yeah, I appreciate
that. So when it comes to this subject
particularly on this on this particular
question um I'm just expressing how if I
were to go with the view that the
scriptures have been corrupted if what
I'm looking at it doesn't seem like
that's what the Quran teaches because it
tells them to judge by
you're claiming that the Quran does say
that the scriptures are unchanged. It's
a very weak claim like a very very weak
claim.
How why is it weak? That's the thing
when you bring up specific verses, I
can't tell you the context and the
interpretation of the specific verses
because I didn't study the specific.
So then how you know it's weak.
But because I've studied the overall
message of the Quran and the overall
like message of the prophet.
So So like that's what and I look I I
like your opinion when you say when you
say that your this particular position
is weak. You're that means that you have
reasons on why it's not strong. It's
it's weak. So like you said that you
studied it which I respect. I want to
know like give it to me like what what
exactly makes what I said a weak
position. I do have to ask like I'm sure
you've studied this too like with regard
this is like more so like what really
stands out to me as to assign the like
of the corruption of the Bible for
example and like the in the religion of
Christianity is like the council of Nika
with emperor Constantine where he
gathered all those people together and
then then decided okay this is the one
true view of Christianity that we're
going to have and a lot of priests were
executed as well
well not not at the not at this at the
result of the council na so but you're
you you're you know you know about it so
yeah the council na was about them
addressing a heretic named Aras who was
going against the deity of Christ while
the church was was an inconsistent on
the deity of Christ. So, but he was
getting a following and so Constantine
wanted unity in the church. That's why
he called the council and they refuted
him from
but even like with the addition of like
Christmas as being a originally starting
as a pagan holiday be integrated into
the religion of Christianity, right?
That's debatable.
No, but like but like we we have seen
like you know like but then you know
like the the Romans and the Greeks had
that as a holiday pagan holiday or not
they celebrated.
I I I don't I don't I don't know too
much but but wouldn't it like if we're
if we're going
known thing as well I think that like
Christmas is debated like so is it a
like but let's let's let's say I let's
say I go with you right
is that would that also cuz I mean the
the the pagan Arabs they used to
circumbulate the the the cabba
themselves they used to you know they
used to rever the the the stone as well
and now and then the reason why is
because prophet Abraham peace be upon
him they they're you know like
essentially their grandfather like you
know like where the Arabs with the
building of the cabba we came with began
with Abraham his practices continue
through their culture. However, idolatry
was brought in by people later
generations and then brought in the
idols. So they continue the customs of
circ circum you know circulating the
kaba and uh you know during the the
omrah where they go to you know visit
where they make pilgrimage to the kaba.
This this tradition stayed prominent in
the Arabian peninsula but of course the
idol the idol worship and everything
came in and corrupted the original
religion of Abraham.
I I hear you. I I haven't seen anything
that suggests that Abraham that that was
a tradition or thing that Abraham
started. That's that's like we the
earliest stuff that we get of that is
the pagan Arabs. So like that's again
like with Islam we believe that uh this
is like it's the uh continuation in in
the essentially of of the Abrahamic
religion prophet. We we believe that
Moses uh Abraham uh Jesus peace be upon
all of them and and prophet Muhammad
they all they all preach the same
message of pure monotheism right so and
of course like uh you know the prophet
Abraham when he built the cabba and
established that worship as well like um
you know the Arab communities in the
area we're monotheistic and it was only
later generations where somebody went to
another tribe found this idol and it was
like oh like they're like the other
tribe what is this idol for like oh this
brings us like something he brought the
idol over and that's when that then
that's when it became corrupted is
through that but then the practices of
you know making the pilgrimage and
everything the umrah at that time was
done all over the Arabian peninsula that
was
based on what
based on like you know what what
Abraham's uh teaching but then again I'm
not now you're going into more details
that I don't have the full details and I
don't want to say anything wrong
no worries well I I I'll bypass that I
hear what you're saying but you said
something interesting we could we could
segue
uh that they that they said they taught
the same message do you is hold the
position that Jesus was a Muslim.
Yes. Muslim is a Muslim the definition
of a Muslim is someone who submits to
the will of God. One who one who
worships God alone.
Okay. So when you say one who submits
the will to God. Uh you you're talking
about a specific concept of God, right?
It can't be who a statute or a human
being but it has to be it's a particular
concept of God that you're talking
about, right?
It's a just the wonders of God. Having a
creator, having uh no physical form, no
like bounds of it outside of time and
space,
no children,
doesn't begin nor begotten, no partners.
Okay, good.
So, if I were to ask you, how would you
prove to me that Jesus was a Muslim,
that he submitted to this idea of God
that you guys just described to me? How
would you how would you demonstrate?
Frustrated.
Why would he be frustrated? He takes
frustration to the to the to God, right?
He worships God.
Okay. The Bible.
So, okay. So that's Matthew 26:39. Good
reference. It says, "And going a little
further, Jesus fell on his face and
prayed." So there's the prostration. And
he prayed, "Father, if it be possible,
let this cup pass from me, but not my
will, let your will be done." So in that
prostration, he's prostrating to who he
says is his father. So can you be a
Muslim and believe that that Allah is
your father?
No. to a father in the sense that like
and think about it too like like a
father in the sense of like you know
where it's like a birth like in that
sense like we also like throughout the
Bible I'm saying like it's saying like
uh I'm sure because the wording has been
made to do father right he's making
prostration right he's making
prostration to
to his father
to god but like father is that like do
you make frustration to your father not
down in English right
well yeah it came down in Greek so um
and then but this is
what what the word is in Greek yeah It's
pater in Greek. It means father.
It always meant father biological
father.
Well, no, just you could be you could be
father in by adoption, father by, you
know, biological father in a close
relationship.
Many different people.
Yeah. But is is so I would ask is Allah
a father?
You call him father?
Yeah. They call him father. Yeah. The
priest and stuff. So I would I would ask
you guys this. Is Allah a father in any
sense? Whether it's metaphorical or
literal?
That's how you define it. Father is just
a word. What's the definition of what
does the word father mean?
Yeah. Like is he is he a father in any
way?
Define it.
Well, it doesn't like I'm saying anyway
definition and I'll tell you if it's a
yes or no.
Okay. So I I I think that so the
question is when you say father that's
someone who you have a close
relationship with a close bond with who
is a father figure to you. Um you know
you're using the words father to define
father. Well, well, no. I'm I'm
describing the role of what a father is.
Like I think a father is you could be
a father. I was on it stronger
relationship. Yes. You're connected to
him. Yes. He's a father figure. You're
using like the words father figure.
Yeah. Yeah. So, but these are these are
ways that these are ways that we how we
know what a father is. That's what I'm
saying. So, like is is Allah a can you
say that Allah is a father in any way?
That's what I'm telling you. If you
describe to me what the definition of
father that you are trying to say.
No, no. I'm saying anyway. What what all
the all the things that we know that
father to mean, what does it mean? What
what is he a father in any way?
Father like what we define you're
defining as father is like someone who
births a child and everything.
Either either you could be you could
birth a child or you can adopt a child
or you can take some somebody under your
wing and have that type of relation like
that type of bond and relationship as a
father and a son. Like that's you know
you can it could be it could be literal
or figurative metaphorical spiritual
spiritual father. You know what I'm
saying? Is Allah a father in any of
those senses?
The problem is you're using the word
father to describe what you mean by
father. So it's just a circular
I don't I don't think I did that.
You did you just said you have a father
relationship with you're like a father
after I just described the role of a
father. So I used what I do the
descriptions to to to strong
relationship and you have that like
connection with them.
Yeah. I said I said I said one who sires
like births, one who adopts one who
Yeah. Do you believe that you can even
have some type of like a spiritual
father like he's he's spiritually uh you
know uh that bond that you know it's
it's not just a slave or a servant but
has that bond of what we know a father
to be.
There we go. You said not just a slave
then.
Got you. Okay. So then Allah is not a
father in any sense.
Yeah. And the definitions that you've
given
by what you've said.
All right. So here's what I will ask
you. Is there a correct definition or
like that's why I said in any way is
there a way where you can refer to Allah
as your father? Is there a correct way
to do that?
To my knowledge um I don't no I don't
and then and then again I think this
with the specific wording this goes into
deeper this is like Islamic fundamental
as well.
Yes.
And then again I don't think I don't of
course this is a point where it gets a
bit like where I don't want to say
something that is incorrect according to
right. Yes.
So I think it's best if like I don't
think this is the we're not the ones to
No, it's okay.
It's also just a linguistic argument
that we're not.
It's it's not linguistic. It's no
because it's it's theological. It's an
So if it's
when when the Quran identifies like says
Allah is not a father. He's he's he
doesn't beget nor is he begotten. Uh you
can only come to him as a as a servant
and he's your master. That's what Allah
says. That's chapter 19 vers 93. So he
he rejects this idea of being a father
in any way. Okay? And so it's not just
linguistic, oh well, you know, we're
playing with words. No, this is a
theological matter. So Jesus is
identifying God as his own father. Is he
a Muslim when he does that?
But what I'm telling you is the word
father that is in the Bible. We're
arguing on what it truly what Jesus was
trying to say when he said father. No,
because what? No, what I'm saying is it
doesn't matter what he meant by it is
that because if in no way Allah is a
father. So it doesn't if he meant it in
this way, this way, this way, or that
way, it don't matter cuz Allah is not a
father at all.
It doesn't matter. It's a word like we
don't even know. I mean, I don't know
the original word, and I don't know.
It's
if if you if you go to Aramaic, it's
aba,
but it does not change anything to
whether I understand what the context of
that word meant at the time. It's like
the word Lord. It could mean so many
different things,
right? So like if I were to ask you for
example, is Allah a lord in any sense?
I would again tell you define the word
Lord and then I'll tell you what.
Come on, man. You you know he is.
Yeah. We don't we don't have to go into
We're in the same agreement of the word
Lord, then yes. Well, no, cuz I I I when
I say
you're telling me lord is someone who is
like
for example
I don't know the exact definition of the
let's say let's say leader of a land for
example or something let's say sovereign
like ruler over something
he's ruler over the heavens and the
earth yes control over
yes so you so that is in a sense what
lord means right so when I say is Allah
a lord in any sense when I say any sense
It covers all bounds of what Lord means
cuz we know Lord can mean different
things.
What I'm telling you is we don't know
what the word father and the actual word
that was used what
we do know the word means. I don't know
all the meanings that for you and you
don't when I ask you what are the
meanings that
okay so so at least at least for now we
know that according to Islam Allah is
not a father in any sense right can we
agree to that
I agree okay I think it's rather like
the father says
like in in
right
he was not you know um
he doesn't begin nor is he begotten
nor is he begotten right
so like
you know doesn't have any children Y
that definition of father of having
children having uh you know you know
giving birth or any sense like that
having something that is equal to you or
related to you like that definition of
father you can say no based on the Quran
right
now is he a father in any other
definition
now the thing is the other definition of
father
like adopted or something
okay I don't I like then again like our
definitions or like what you're saying
is father in this I think honestly we're
just going to go back and forth
all right so let me let me just I think
that this verse will clear this
Chapter 19:93
it says there is none in the heavens or
the earth that can come to Allah except
as a slave. That's it. You so you that
he makes it clear whether it's begotten
or unbegotten doesn't matter. Adopted
figurative he says no one can come to
him as more than a slave
because everything is the creation of
God. Everything no matter what it may be
is a creation. It is a subserving to the
will of God.
No problem. Right? No problem at all
with that. I understand that you know
the theology behind it. So my point is
is that the Quran is crystal clear that
like there's there is no confusion on
this. You cannot identify Allah as a
father in any way, shape or form. You
know what I'm saying? So when Jesus
prostrates and he prostrates, how you
guys doing? When Jesus prostrates and he
prostrates to to the father. When Jesus
prostrates, right, and he's prostrating
to the father,
that means that okay, according to that
verse, he's outside of Islam, right?
It's then again, the Bible uses the word
father in whatever sense it's using,
right? But then like but then again like
prostration is one thing as a form of
worship, is it not? He's worshiping.
Yes, he's worshiping the father.
The word father is used within the Bible
for different context.
Correct.
Yes. And sometimes it's not speaking. It
says that God is the father of uh
Israel.
Yeah. Does that mean they're all the
sons of God?
Yes, they're all sons of God, but in a
different sense that Jesus is.
Exactly. I'm saying the word father
could be used in different aging in a
different sense where you said like he's
the father of Israel. That means he what
define that.
So he birthed Israel as a nation. and he
created them as a nation and not just
that they're servants of his but he sees
them as his sons that he adopted that he
grafted in.
So they're all the sons of
God of God by adoption
including Jesus. So it's not trinity.
Well well yeah no so that they're
they're sons of God. Like I said you
broke down like there's context. They're
sons of God in a different context than
Jesus with with Jesus. He's the begotten
son of God. Israel is different, but in
no no way does it match what has
You're the one that's defining what the
word father means here and then defining
it.
Well, no, the context does. The context
does.
Well, there is no context that tells you
that Jesus is the direct son.
Yeah. He he says he says, "For God so
loved John 3:16, for God so loved the
world that he sent his only begotten son
only." So he only has one begotten son
that whosoever believes in him should
not perish.
And the word father is used multiple
times. So you're just changing the
definition. context. The context give
the meaning of the word. The context
will show you how the word is being
used.
I'm not used to
well versed in the Bible.
Yeah, that's okay. But like what you're
asking is a good you're making a good
point.
But my like this is a good point to
circle back to what we were talking
about earlier when it says the reminder.
The reminder is like the definition is
made depending on the context. So you
didn't understand that when it came to
the Quran?
No, I did. Okay. That's
I did. What I'm saying is based on the
context according to the context of the
Quran and we look at these scriptures
the reminder is the previous scriptures.
It's not based on the context of number.
Okay. Well, I don't want to get too far
off now but
so so let me so let me ask you this. Can
you guy can you be a Muslim? Right. Uh
and I want to ask the brother this cuz
he was he brought this up. Can you be a
Muslim and believe that God is your
father?
No. As in in the sense that
any sense.
Okay. Now see
worth playing hard is a very conricting.
Okay.
I think I think that's in look when you
say when I say is can you can you
believe that God is your father in any
sense that covers every meaning of
father.
Give us your definition of father right
now.
Yes.
What is it?
So okay I'm not Yeah. Yeah. I got you.
So
English to me is like there's one
definition of father like he b like he
So okay. So, so in and so when it comes
to Jesus, when it means that he's the
son of God, it means that he comes from
the father's essence. He has the same
essence as the father.
Oh, like Buddhism where like everything.
No, not Buddhism. It's just that the
father and the son have the same
essence. So, he comes forth from the
father's essence. Kind of like how uh
light comes forth from the sun.
The father the son comes forth from the
father's essence. It's something like
that. So that's in that sense he shares
the same essence as the father and is
therefore identified as his son. Now my
thing is is that that type of theology
doesn't matter because Allah is not a
father in that way. He's not a father by
adoption. He's not a father
figuratively. He's not a father
metaphorically. In no sense is Allah a
father. Right? We can agree there.
Right? Excuse me. The thing is you're
using multiple like ways to define
father right
in this Allah can guide Allah can can
you know is is our creator
we are not related to him in the sense
of like a blood relation or
blood relation or spiritual
okay no but then like
okay I know the thing is
I of course like do not want to say
anything wrong
but the thing is like this is a lot of
word play that's going on
I don't think so.
I think there's a lot of workplay going
on
where when we define father
our baseline definition of father is
blood relationship.
Right. Right. That's the that's the
immediate understanding.
These other definitions of father are
not are outside this mainstream idea of
and like the book definition of what the
father.
Right. Right. You have you have adopt
you have all these all these different
context. So in those senses like I do
not want to define father with those
words whatsoever like father being
related to these things at all like
you're a father by adoption you're a
father by spirit these things like we
should not define father we should use
maybe you can use like another term for
that as well but what I'm saying is like
like this is like more so like to clear
up what we're talking about right when
we refer to father we're referring to
parental direct relationship right like
that right
you're you're also defining father with
other terms but in and of itself can
like it makes it a bit like confusing to
understand what you're the same right
but what I want to say is this as well I
think it's best to clear this up if you
want with someone who might have more
knowledge on both the languages right
so I looked at what says
absolutely not like he he refuts in any
way that Allah is a father like all of
them
to me is the definition of a father is
maybe the generic definition of father
not just that he understands it by
adoption too he understands like the
Christian theology he refuts it you know
refuted like you already said it our
only relationship with God is we are his
slave.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. So, thank you. So,
that's why I'm like there is no
confusion like there's like we we've the
Quran cleared this up.
That's why I said it's a linguistic
argument. We're not arguing about the
theology.
It is theology because
it's not for us. It's not for us. We're
just a slave. That's it.
Right. But that's but that's that's your
that's your theological relationship
with Allah. the theologically you can
only be a slave of Allah. You cannot be
a son, right? That's theological. It's
not just semantics. It's it's
theological. So, and when you're as a
Muslim, you know, you can only come to
Allah as a servant, as a slave. You
cannot be a son. So, if someone is
saying that they are a son of Allah,
they're not a Muslim. They are outside
of the of what the Quran says.
And then you're not going to use this.
If we then say no, we're then going to
say okay then Jesus therefore wasn't a
Muslim because of this definition.
Right.
Correct. What I'm saying is we don't
know what he meant. We first of all
don't know.
It doesn't matter. But then also no
because the way the Bible was also
conceived like it was created
hundreds of years like like a generation
or two after the death of Jesus like the
Bible like was the Bible not I mean like
not the like after Jesus peace be upon
him came when was the Bible then created
like when is
the New Testament was being written like
uh probably like roughly 40 to 50 years
after Jesus ascended.
Okay. So what's the latest like the
earliest version of the Bible?
The earliest the earliest copy that we
have is a it's a like a small little
manuscript. It's like uh I forget the
date. I think it's like 110 AD.
Um
that's the earliest copy, right?
That's that's the earliest like that's
the earliest little manuscript. Yeah.
So the evidence that we have so far like
it's just it's a copy. That's how we
know this earlier.
So like the earliest preservation of the
Bible is not nor the original. It's a
It's a copy of something
that's original
that we also don't have and it's 100
years after the the
It's not 100 No, it's no it's not No,
it's not 100 years. Like so Jesus left
in 70 AD. Uh I'm sorry, not 70 AD. Uh 33
AD.
So if the AD though, right?
Yeah. So if AD 33 AD Jesus died in 33 AD
when he died,
right? Well, okay. Well, ascended. Let's
go with ascended. He ascended back into
heaven in 33 AD. Okay. So 110 AD that's
not 100 years later. That's I'm not
quick on math but okay.
Right. So that's just 80 years later and
that's a copy. So that means that the
originals were obviously closer to his
time.
Copy to can be changed too, right? Like
the copy is not the perfect. It's not
even also the full copy. It's a sliver,
is it not?
Well, well there's no there's no
evidence of that being changed. All of
it say the same. But but how come, for
example, when Paul was, you know, going
on his things and like calling out
people for their wrong, he even opposed
the disciples, did he not?
He only opposed Peter for being a
hypocrite towards Gentiles.
No, but then again, like you're
opposing, you know, one of the closest
to Jesus.
Yeah. He called him out because he was
being a hypocrite.
He held him accountable. But he but he's
also like is he not been also changing
and like you know like he's he's maybe
uh okay now now I'm getting to Christian
history that I'm not very familiar with.
Yeah. So there was a situation where
Peter uh decid like once like he was
eating with the with the Gentiles,
right? But then when the Jews came
around, he left the Gentiles and tried
to act like he was not cool with them.
It was with the Jews only. And so Paul
was like, "You're acting like a
hypocrite. That's not what the gospel
teaches where Jews and Gentiles are all
one and the same in according to the
gospel." So he called him out on that.
Okay.
And Peter was corrected.
Okay. Okay.
You know, but but in line with this,
like not to veer off so far about Jesus
being a Muslim with what we know about
Islamic doctrine on, you know, the
relationship, if Jesus is teaching that
he's the son of God, right? Like in the
verse that you gave me, then according
to this verse, he's not a Muslim, right?
No. Okay. Then again, I want to pull up
a verse from the Quran to kind of go
against what you said. This is in surah
madia uh ayah number 15 116 and for 117
if you want to read both of them and
it's like the translation if you want to
read both those verses. So like even
says like um and I didn't go will ask
Jesus like
me say no right
and then if you go to the next ayah as
well
uh I never told them anything except
what you ordered me to say worship Allah
my lord and your lord and I as a witness
over them as long as I remained among
them but when you but when you took me
you were the witness over them and you
are witness you are a witness over all
So like then again like we leave Jesus
peace be upon him, servant of God,
messenger of God, right?
We are coming.
Is it still good? We can record it.
Yeah. Like we you know servant of God,
messenger of God.
Yeah.
Like the definition of father that like
the thing is we live it just these
servant of God. Messenger of God.
I don't got another one. You got another
one?
Um
sorry.
But you know with with it being like a
father-son relationship in the sense
that like it's like you know like like
we've seen in in our day like father son
relationship this we we refute this
whatsoever like completely right but we
believe Jesus peace be upon him is a
Muslim he submits to the will of God he
worshiped God and God alone he's a
prophet of God so he pre the message of
pure monarchism right
so Jesus is a Muslim
I know that's what you believe when I
asked you to demonstrate it you brought
me a verse from the Bible and So you
quoted where Jesus prostrates to his
father.
Okay. Then but then again like what the
the word they father used this this is
where like
can we at least say that according to
that verse this would show that Jesus is
not in line with his law at least
according to that verse
because it's a sense because the fact
the act of Jesus prostrating a form of
worship to to God is that is worship.
But you you told you told me like this
is why I set the we set the foundations
earlier that being a Muslim is
submitting to a the particular concept
of God that you told me, right? No sons,
no daughters, absolutely singular. We we
we already went through that. So I was
like, okay, so can you show me that
Jesus submitted to and believed in that
concept of God? And so as a result, he
showed me this verse. So does this verse
line up with the concept of God that you
gave me?
Okay. Then but then like with the word
father too it gets a bit weird because
you're defining father in one way.
No it's not it's not about how I define
it. It's in any way.
But you're defining father in that sense
but then like
I haven't defined it.
But then but then we use father like
father is a reference to god right in
the bible.
Correct.
In the bible they're saying they when
they say like the father they're
referring to god right.
Yes.
So then like so when maybe you know like
okay now I'm going to make I'm not going
to make an assumption but I don't want
to say anything else. Then I also want
to say like we're reaching a kind of a
limit here of to where my knowledge is
with regards to the Bible's maybe
original wording and and translations
and everything.
You know, you're right. It's the
original word.
The word is aba. He says aba in Aramaic.
Yes. But I think as well it's best to
speak with a scholar that's more learned
than us about this because he can maybe
provide you with a better answer and
better thing because right now I think
we're hitting a limit and it's and I
don't think we're going to give justice
to the verse in in like in your text as
well as to what it means and and even
like uh you know with with our own
definitions as well. So like I I don't
want to basically lead you astray nor
say the wrong thing. I think we should
just like kind of leave it as is. They
can give you someone to speak to you
like an email or a phone number. You can
speak with them and I think they can
provide you with a much better answer
than what I can provide. Like there's
scholars who have done the same who have
spent a lot more time than all of us
have applied. So
I think speaking with them you would get
the direct answers that you're looking
for.
Yeah, absolutely. And and I'll
definitely take the information. So let
me ask you this. Not not as theology
from what the Bible say.
Well, so see that but that's that is my
thing. When I said demonstrate to me
that Jesus is a Muslim, what he did was
is he quoted the Bible.
Yeah. But there are many verses in the
Quran.
Yeah. I was reading something from from
what your beliefs were
to kind of show you that like through
this submitting to the will, praying to
God is what a Muslim does. They pray.
Yes.
No. No. No. No, wait up. And then now
you're going to say, oh, like he's
praying he's praying to the father
because cuz as a Muslim, it matters who
you're doing these actions to, right?
You can't be praying to like this pole
and that's the one true God who created
all things and be a Muslim. It has to
there's a a particular specific concept
of God that you have to submit to. If
you don't submit to that, then you're
not a Muslim. That's my point. And so,
if we're going by his definition, the
verse shows that Jesus is not a Muslim.
I think that's a fair position for me to
have at least for now.
I think we can't we can't because you're
defining it in one way and we're we're
we're saying it's it's another way too.
rather than
because we also throughout the Quran
there's many instances you know speaking
of Jesus peace be upon him
of his you know example of him being he
is a Muslim in the Quran he's defined as
like he's
yeah that's that's the that's the claim
that I'm challenging and here's why
because obviously Jesus comes about you
know 600 years before Islam before the
Quran right now if you guys so you guys
are saying that oh well Jesus lines up
with the with Islam as well. We go back
to So you're making a historical claim.
You're saying historically Jesus was a
Muslim. He believed in the same concept
of God that Muhammad reveals in the
Quran. So
in order to demonstrate that you don't
quote the Quran cuz that's the the Quran
is in question.
I only quoted it to I only quoted that
particular part from the Bible to show
like we redefine Muslim is one who
submits to the will of God. One who
worships God and God alone. Right.
Yes. He's then in this case worshiping
God. Not and then now you're going to
say, "Oh, now you're going to bring in
the definition of the father." But like
in this like but then then again
because it matters who he's praying to.
No, but then also that's the wording
that's used in the Bible too cannot be
trusted. I'm sorry.
Then that then why quote it? See that
that's my point.
No, I was just saying like no I was I
was talking about active worship,
bowing, prostrating, asking for
assistance or whatever it may be from
God.
So So that's what I'm asking.
I can quote the Quran many many
I know. So, so this, so this is what I'm
saying, brother.
If if the words of the Bible can't be
trusted and you know, when we look at
this verse, you know, we see the
problems there. Can we least be honest
at least with the text? Not that you
believe the text, but let's be honest
with the text. According to the text,
that Jesus that's in that text does not
line up with Islam. Can we at least
admit that?
No, we can't. Here, let me say let me
I'm going to say one thing. Sorry. He's
he quoted the Bible to speak your
language in a sense for you to
understand. There's multiple verses in
the Quran where Jesus is a Muslim
because we believe a Muslim is someone
who prostrates to the one and only
creator. He has attributes that are
similar in all three texts. If you can
find me, if you have proof that the
Bible has not been tampered with, I'll
believe you. But there's multiple
versions of the Bible. If you can find
me another religious uh text that has
been tampered with, that has not been
tampered with, then I'll it'll most
likely be similar to the Quran. Quran is
the only vers only book in 1,400 years
not a single word not a single text of
it has been touched has been changed has
nothing has happened to it that's why we
follow this way so these are the
attributes we have the surah called
where it says that say he is Allah who
is one Allah the most
what does he say he's the ultimate
refuge
he neither begets nor is born it says
this verse in the Quran god does not
beget he does not have a father nor does
he have a son, we cannot believe that
you could call your creator father
because what happens to a son when he
gets older? He has kids and becomes a
father himself. God is not a role that
you can have throughout your life. There
can only be one creator, the ultimate
creator of everything.
Beautiful. So with that being said, with
that clear theology,
yes,
when Jesus in Matthew 26:39 that he
quoted says that Jesus is praying to his
father, that in that verse, I know that
you don't believe it. I'm just saying
according to that text, that does not
line up with Islam, right? Matthew did.
No, he didn't. That 600 years after he
died.
No, it didn't. But, but Okay. But look,
I'm not your scholar said.
No. No. Listen, listen, listen. I'm not
talking about the reliability of the
text. Let's say that this Okay, look.
I'm with you. This is what I'm saying.
I'm going with you. The text is
corrupted. It's not trustworthy.
However, the text says things. It says
word. It has words on it.
I'm not saying follow it.
I'm saying that when we look at what the
text says, as untrustworthy as it is,
corrupted and everything, right? We
don't believe in it. But when we look at
it, we got I mean we can read it and
according to that text that we don't
believe in, it doesn't line up with
Islam. Right?
Tell you that specific verse because I
mean I can't tell you that specific
verse cuz I have not studied it and just
like earlier we're talking about the
Quran.
Well, let me let me let him into this
really quick like so that text not in
Matthew but in the Bible it also says
that the earth is flat.
No, it doesn't say but you're segway.
Okay. It also says that women who do not
cover their heads should be shaved and
No, it doesn't. That's only talking
that's talking about prayer,
my brother. You're you're going away
from the question.
No, but I'm I'm trying to show you like
I'm trying to like go with you.
Go. If you're going to follow this text,
follow it.
No, no, listen. I'm saying I'm Look, you
said it's un untrustworthy. Got it. It's
unreliable.
Granted, I'm just asking you to be
honest with what that verse says in that
verse that you don't trust that is that
is corrupted.
That verse, what it says about Jesus
does not line up with Islam, right?
when it's so it says that Jesus
studied the Bible fact
by
if you haven't if you haven't studied
the Bible fully then how can you say
that it's corrupted
you see like that's corrupted historical
would you call me would you study a
science book by someone who did not
study science
but so so if you're saying that then you
can't tell me it's corrupted if you
don't know nothing about it
okay so if I was to teach you about cars
right and I'm not a mechanic would you
listen to me
no
but why did you not listen to me cuz I I
have a book about cars
so then why are you telling me it's
corrupted when you're not a theologian
or biblical me as a whole. It's just
like he doesn't know anything about cars
water. I can listen to him. Just like
that.
So then why would I listen to you when
you say it's corrupted?
Because we agree.
No, I don't agree.
Why is that?
Because you're not you're not a biblical
mechanic. I have no reason to trust what
you're saying. You haven't brought me
parts in the Bible that make it
contradictory.
Again,
all I need to know not to listen to it.
But again, you don't know nothing about
the Bible. So how can I trust when you
say certain things contradictory? You
feel me?
You don't know if I'm not a good
mechanic or not.
Listen to So you got to demonstrate it.
That's the point.
Exactly. And then once I demonstrate it,
I fail. So, so this is what I'm saying.
I'm gonna give you an example. Maybe you
can understand if I flip it. Um, I don't
believe in the Quran. I'm a Christian. I
do not trust the Quran. I don't trust
what it says. However, I know that the
Quran says Muhammad is the last
messenger. I can't say that it doesn't
say that. Even though I don't believe
it. You know what I'm saying? But I it
would be dishonest of me to try to
critique the Quran and say, "Well, no,
you know what? It doesn't say that. You
know, it don't you know that that lines
up with Christianity. I I can't do that
if I'm being honest.
So, I'm trying to have you do the same
is I know you don't believe in the
Bible. I know you don't trust the Bible,
but be honest with the what the verse
says.
Why don't you trust the
I'll get to that in a sec. I promise.
That's a good question and I want to
deal with that.
Because the reason you don't subject and
the reason I don't trust the Bible are
very different. So, you cannot ask me to
do the same. It would be double
standard.
No, I'm asking you to hold the same
criteria and standard that you're
holding to that you're applying to me.
If you're saying look
you can you can dude when you're saying
look when you're saying uh I don't trust
I don't trust the Bible it's unreliable
you know what I'm saying I'm als I also
don't know I haven't studied the Bible
right so I can't interpret it however I
don't trust it uh from what I know as
from what I believe it's corrupted fine
but when we look at a verse what the
Bible says that I know you don't believe
in it I know you don't trust it but you
can see what It says and you can you're
you're like you have a mind. So you can
look at a verse if a verse says like for
example any in any book if a verse says
in any book there's three gods does that
verse line up with Islam?
No.
Exactly. Even though you don't so you
don't believe in that.
Right. But you can understand it doesn't
line up with Islam. So I'm asking you to
do the same.
The Bible the verse that he quoted Jesus
says that he's praying to his father.
Does that line up with Islam?
There is no wait. Let him answer
more money.
I can't answer that for you. And the
reason being is because
what?
I could find verses in the Quran where
it says Jesus is a Muslim. Is that true?
No. No. I'll find a verse from the Quran
that says Jesus is a Muslim and I'm
going to say, "Can you accept this?"
There's no verse in the Quran that says
that.
It does.
Show me a verse. Okay, go ahead. Give me
a verse that says Jesus is a Muslim. It
doesn't exist.
That's a whole chapter.
Yeah. And then in that entire chapter,
it doesn't say Jesus is a Muslim.
Muslim gods.
Doesn't say he's a Muslim.
From Muslim means someone who submit
submits to God.
To what?
To God. To the will of God.
To what God specifically? The one who
has no sons and daughters. Right.
Right. So if I'm if there's a line in a
book where Jesus is saying that he's the
son of God, does that line up with
Islam? Yes or no?
Say I am the son of God. Yes, it does.
No. But does Wait, I have a question.
Like does the Bible like use the word
God independently or does it always
refer to as my father the father? Uh it
there's sometimes where there's God,
there's and sometimes there's father. Mo
most of the time Jesus refers to God as
father. He doesn't use the word god. Um
uh usually you usually he says father
then I also like want to go back to you
know I know like you know youtuber too.
So you spoken with like sh.
Yeah. Yeah.
Um and I'm sure like as I'm saying like
you know the the level of conversation
you have with him much higher and much
more knowledgeable than
not really. I'm going to be real with
you.
Really?
To be honest with you, this the this was
better in quality than cuz it's there's
a lot of man is high up there. So it's
there's more ego.
471. You know the old people of the book
said Allah is but the truth was no more
than a messenger of Allah which he
bestowed upon Mary.
He's no more than a messenger of Allah.
That's what it says.
Well, actually the Quran doesn't say
that.
Yes, it does.
I know. Look, I know the English
translation says it. In the Arabic
doesn't translate,
but but then again translation. Okay.
You can't. You can't. You're trying to
get Okay, we'll put We'll put
Remember Remember you said in the Quran
this whole loop?
No, no. I'm trying to I'm trying to save
you time.
I'm trying to save you time. In the
Quran, it doesn't say Jesus is a Muslim.
Number one is you're asking whether we
believe that the Trinity is in the
Bible. That's what you're asking. That's
what you're asking whether we believe
that the Trinity is in the Bible.
No, that's what I'm asking.
That is what you're asking if like if
Jesus is the son of God in the Bible and
whether that agrees in the Quran. Okay,
that's what you're saying.
Yeah, basically.
Yeah. So, I'm telling you I don't know
whether the trinity is in the Bible
because I have not studied the Bible.
I understand.
Okay. So, that question is done.
Well, I didn't ask about the trinity. I
we brought up a specific verse where
Jesus says
we studied that verse.
I know. But you know, but you saw what
it says.
No. Again, I'm telling you like I can't
make a interpretation.
It's not about just like earlier you
were trying to make an interpretation of
the cursing.
No, you're missing you're missing it.
You're missing it. I'm not asking you to
interpret it. This is not a verse you
need to interpret. Like for example,
you need to interpret.
Okay. So when when the Quran says
Muhammad is the last messenger, does
that take interpretation?
Yes, it does. Every single verse in the
Quran needs interpretation. You can't
come and tell me what the Quran.
So the so the Quran is not clear alone.
When it says Muhammad is the last
messenger, I need to interpret that. You
need to fully understand what the verse
means. You need to like be able
when the verse says Muhammad is the last
messenger. What else could that mean?
Pick any verse you want.
I'm picking that one. That's I feel like
that's okay. Here's another one. Allah
is Allah is one.
Allah is one. Is that unclear?
We fully understand what that means
because of what the scholars said. The
scholars were right from one verse. You
get a full book of 40 pages.
So, so you're and that's why I'm telling
you, you're coming with ignorance. And
why are you saying I'm coming with
ignorance? Because you do you know tapir
you can how do you know that
it takes 30 years to study. We haven't
even studied
well I haven't studied everything but I
read I read when I read yes I can
reading and understanding is two very
different things.
Yeah I read and understand what top says
we're we're reading top too but we do
not say we understand
that's fine that's that's you
individually I've on the top that I've
read I've understood it.
I also want to say like I guess like
with the
one second one second like you said you
read the tips.
Yeah. Why did you read the tips here?
Because I want to make sure. I want to
see what the scholars say about it.
Exactly. That's the point. So whenever
you're bringing up a particular verse,
you don't make your own opinion of it
based on the English, based on whatever
limited knowledge you have. That's why I
said ignorance. Limited knowledge. You
replace it with limited knowledge. You
come with limited knowledge compared to
the scholars that are able to make the
or that have the skill and the ability
to make.
Okay. So you you're not at that level
and you'll never be at that level.
Yeah. Thanks for that. But so so what
none of us are will be at that level to
make their own.
Well, that's that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is is that okay, the
Quran says that it is a clear admitting
that we can't we don't know the context
and we don't know the
Yeah, but you're saying your own.
No, but you're you're saying that on
verses that are extremely simple that
even an 11-year-old child can
understand.
But even then you should know what it
is. I'm I'm guessing with the Bible if
there's a form of tapid for that verse.
Is there knowledge?
Yeah. Yeah. You we have what is called
the church father. So that we have their
interpretations.
We we don't want to talk about that
verse because we have not studied the
church.
I understand what you're saying. But but
what I'm asking is this bro let's say
you don't have a taps around. Let's say
I'm in the middle of a jungle and all I
have is the Quran. Am I able Wait, wait,
just please let me let me ask this
question. Let me answer this. Let me ask
this question. If I'm in the middle of a
jungle with just the Quran, am I able,
if I can read the Quran in my language,
am I able to receive accurately the
message that Allah wants me to receive?
I don't know.
Wait, you don't know?
With the Quran?
Yes. If I just have the Quran alone and
I'm in the jungle, just the Quran, me
and the Quran,
have misinterpretations on it.
So I I can receive the specific Quran
verses that says that even people who
are of very little knowledge, they
understand to a certain extent to be
still considered. Beautiful. And the
Quran is meant to academic and the
nonacademic. I understand the general
idea of why you're saying this specific
verse.
Well, that's what I'm saying. So, the
Quran the Quran literally says that it's
easy to remember. It's it's made clear
for those who ponder on it. So, but what
you're telling me is that even if I
ponder on it, I the Quran isn't clear. I
need to go to someone else to see what
they said and then see what they said in
order for something to be made clear to
me. That goes against what the Quran
said. understand it 100%.
Man, I feel like I'm defending the
Quran.
That's only if you don't know the Arabic
language itself, cuz the Quran is
revealed in Arabic, but no one speaks
nowadays. So, it's like, you know, like
there's like Shakespeare in English,
like that's like the Quran at the or
like the Arabic at the time of the
ancient Arab. And so because of that
there's like there scholars that like
specifically study that level of Arabic
and like even like Arabic speaking
people don't understand all of the
language and even in like centuries that
have like you know sometimes like Arabic
like like languages changes and there's
like Arabic as well. That's what he's
trying to say. Like some verses do mean
that like interpretation
the translating English are like not
they're not always like the same as they
are in Arabic.
I I I agree with I agree that there's
certain verses that you know you'll need
some expounding on. You need someone
who's knows the language and you know I
understand that I'm asking a lot of
understanding.
So let me let me let me ask her. Let's
see it. Do you think that the verse that
says Muhammad is the last messenger? Do
you think that that verse needs any more
interpretation than that or is it just
plain and clear?
It is.
Yeah. So
when you enter into Islam, when you
submit into Islam, one of the first
things that you declare
exact that he's the last messenger of
Allah,
right? So that's that's what I'm I'm
talking about examples like that. I I
understand that there can be things in
the Quran that are deep that if you
don't know the Arabic and you need to
get some help, you know, I understand
that or do some deeper dive. There are
verses that are even the Quran says
there's verses are clear, some verses
that are unclear, right? Um, so I get
that, but there's clear verses that you
do not have to go anywhere else to
understand like Muhammad is the last
messenger.
I don't need anything else.
But the reminder is not one of those
verses.
Sure. I agree. I point the star.
That's fine.
I just went around and
you sound like you have done your
research and you you know about the
Bible. you know about the verses and
it's admirable that you read the
problem. what can you do? We can get you
in touch with a scholar who will once
again give you direct answers, more
detailed answers than we could give you.
Okay. Yeah, let's uh contact
information.
Yeah, let's let's share contact
Oh my god.
Logic.
[Music]